this is the grounded podcast number
seven with echo Charles and me
Jacqueline willing so grounded podcast
this could become a whole like we could
just do what we're about to do from now
until forever because we're entering a
realm of the world the hips that's kind
of crazy it's the world of YouTube
comments yes but we had a video that
came out that was an excerpt from jockle
podcast which is the other podcast that
we do and but the the excerpt was called
jujitsu wrestling versus jujitsu and you
know we had a conversation and it was a
good conversation but I wouldn't say it
was a comprehensive no right it wasn't
it wasn't comprehensive there's a lot of
things that were that maybe I was
thinking one thing but I didn't explain
it well or you were thinking something
and we didn't connect on it or whatever
so anyways as I read through the
comments there was a lot of comments in
there that I thought well you know
that's a legitimate point or hey that
makes sense or I don't actually know if
I add this thing to it then you really
wrong or I'm wrong or whatever so I
thought it would be interesting just to
kind of look at some of these comments
and and just discuss them a little bit
to add some more context to them because
jiu-jitsu and wrestling are really
complementary I mean they are beautiful
when mixed together I believe the two of
them mixed together is one of the most
all powerful things in the world so
actually it's too bad that the subject
matter is jiu-jitsu versus wrestling
when actually I believe in jiu-jitsu and
wrestling because clearly wrestling
takedowns are the best of all takedowns
by the way I will even say better than
judo takedowns because well judo made
the double leg takedown illegal why
because it was so effective that
wrestlers
there and win now look again this
doesn't mean I don't
judo is awesome yes I've talked about
that we did a pot we had an entire
podcast on judo and exclaimed how
wonderful judo is which it is mmm but
the wrestling takedowns are kind of
superior now look if you're wearing a
geek totally different right
judo takedowns are a lot better well
they're closer to wrestling takedowns
anyways so and here's some of the
comments let's just get into some of
them um this guy says this I'm a
wrestler and it's like this garyun about
it right
wrestling will give the aggression the
muscle memory to stay on your feet never
be on your back get off the ground quick
as well as strength and cardio from
wrestling BJJ will give you submissions
that let wrestling lakhs to finish a
fight
excellent work I will agree with his
authority do you not you're looking at
me like in a strange way well triggered
me with the wrestling's just better than
judo okay okay that was too strong would
say that that's the root of the look I
was giving you that's the root of it
then it's like one of those things were
it that's true a little bit more to that
as well where do doesn't necessarily
only give you the finishes or whatever
it gives you functionality whether you
land on your back or not
so wrestling kind of I mean wrestling
generally speaking yes look it's gonna
depend on the individual too so
generally speaking ok wrestling will
keep you off your back
yes well I have a large assistance right
keeping you however if you turn to your
stomach yes you're just getting your
right if you wind up on your back there
that's when wrestlers have issues one of
the one of the situations or regulars
generally speaking will have issues if
they do wind up on their back yes and
it's a problem it's one either they
can't function at all if the jiu-jitsu
guy can keep him on his back or yeah
like how you said he'll turn over and
then exposes back which is it's a big
that's a big no-no so I think there's
sort of that as well
yeah a couple
other comments be JJ's fight does not
end when you're on your back yeah he's
saying the same thing that you are
I came another comment I came from the
true old school wrestling days when your
coach had better not find you lying on
your back or you suffer a grueling
session of sprints etc that's pretty
cool you're just not allowed to be on
your back no matter what that's legit
that's legit right there here's a
comment says echo is such a softly
spoken unit wrestling is just grappling
without the submissions and ad
submissions and you're dangerous again
that's cool and I get it
but like you just pointed out wrestling
you don't you don't fight off your back
so that's a whole well actually that's a
little bit wrong you do fight off your
back you fight not to be on your back
which is really which is really that's
why it's hard when I go with Taylor when
I go with CEREC who are good wrestlers
it's hard I want to put them on their
back and cross-eyed it's hard to get
them there does that mean they
necessarily give up their back kind of
but they're also using that as a
transition to get out so yeah not to
mention they're doing jiu-jitsu by the
way yes they're doing shit true
judo is often neglected as an
alternative to wrestling for jiu-jitsu
players true again I guess I just need
to like call I retract my statement
right
I totally retract it though
listen fundamentally look if you put a
wrestler versus a judo player and it's a
takedown contest I'm leaning towards the
wrestlers going to take the pro take
your NATO player down okay that's that's
what I'm saying yes and then is it or is
it ten out of ten no it might not be ten
are you saying pure wrestling pure Judy
yes pure wrestling pure judo and then
you got to say noogie
yes once you add the ghee on it some
wrestlers have a hard time adapting to
that yeah saying you made a good point
with where they outlawed the double leg
because of that but then again that then
that just sort of goes back to like
training right where judo is like okay
in this particular sport like we this is
how our training traditions have
for so long or whatever either we adapt
the training to like all takedowns like
this or nah should do which yeah you
think so and that's sort of what
jiu-jitsu does but you know in a judo
scenario or apparently in the judo
scenario they were like a rather than
adapt training and make takedowns part
of like judo maybe their tradition was
too strong or whatever they just
outlawed it in competition which is weak
and then and I've talked to judo players
high-level judo players that are like
yeah that was a bad move it's not good
for the sport just like it's not good
for the jiu-jitsu sport to outlaw
reaping yeah on the knee which sounds
like this horrible thing it's totally
normal and you should be allowed to do
it yeah so there's that
this guy says I was the smallest marine
in my unit and I beat everyone matched
up with me with no official grappling
experience besides being an all-state
wrestler I never knew how much the
wrestling helped me until I was against
some of the biggest marine drama yeah
that's that's a given
yeah you know that's a given that's
legit yeah even if you know jujitsu
let's say but and I'm kind of drawing on
random training experience where even as
a purple belt and you go against a brand
new guy who's like under one year but he
has really good wrestling it's gonna be
way harder to tap that guy out just wait
harder in general so that's how like
yeah if you get guys who go in like new
but aside from just the newness of it
yeah one guy has like a book or on top
of the newness one guy has a lot of
wrestling oh yeah that's a well check
this guy out
okay here's another comment I know a
high-level wrestler full-ride to success
in university success against
international level opponents upon
beginning BJJ he was immediately
effective at gaining positional control
over everyone black belts included in
noogie and marginally less successful
with ghee he wasn't often submitting the
high level guys he knew how to he knew
how to squeeze someone's neck but with
the point system of BJJ he was winning
more often than not he would he would
himself occasionally get caught in
triangles and arm bars in the ghee he
had difficulty passing from full guard
within weeks he was consistently winning
with nogi often vien submissions
Chimaera and Darce within a few months
he was choking high belts with their own
lapels
this was that white belt everyone felt
much better when he was promoted take an
equally level high level equally high
level BJJ student and he wouldn't have
nearly the same success among wrestlers
even given much more time a quality
wrestling base lends itself to learning
other disciplines better than any other
sport edit I'll add that one day no key
and the high level belts quickly had no
qualms going for heel hooks okay I I
pretty much agree with this yeah bro cuz
here's the other thing this guy this
wrestler that he's talking about was an
athlete Yeah right
this guy's a collegiate athlete that had
success against it or not this dudes a
badass straight a full ride full ride
and he said success against that means
beating international level opponents
this is not a normal human no right this
guy's a mutant and he's a Annie wrestled
his whole life right of course he's
gonna look no one's denying this I think
this is just a great comment this is why
you should have your kids wrestle yeah
except for the last like kind of what
his conclusion when he was like oh yeah
since it applied to this one like spec
guys to everybody yes correct what would
it because let's face it I've gone with
wrestlers good wrestlers that don't
adapt well to jujitsu and they are not
hard to submit and I see a purple belt
submitting a high-level wrestler because
they don't have the right kind of
adaptability yeah they don't have that
in their brain yeah and that's a big
part of it where he was like he was
choking guys with like and then he named
these like real basic moves but if
you're against real generally speaking
to where if you're an athlete especially
in like wrestling or grappling and
whatever and you just make 1 2 3 4
adjustments if you can pay attention and
make those little adjustments and still
remain athle remain like all your skills
from before remain the way the way
they're gonna obviously um yeah oh yeah
you can find that kind of success
especially with like you've seen these
guys every once in a while like you'll
get these like badass wrestlers and
they'll come in and they'll just
guillotine everybody because they're
used to that front headlock that's part
of wrestling you know and they'll just
be just a small adjustment
do it to everybody here and that gives
them breakfast and then you throw the
cowcatcher in there which is another
wrestling move the red the cowcatcher to
the to the Cobra choke right that's a
wrestling move all day long I see kids
use that all the wrestling mats and all
of a sudden the wrestling mats become
the wrestling mats of justice here's
another good point my when my daughter
was wrestling she would have like I got
to know you know all the other girls
that wrestled that were good wrestlers
and most of the girls this is in San
Diego which San Diego has really good
wrestling for boys for sure there's some
there's some high schools in San Diego
that are recognized kind of across the
country as really good wrestling
actually where Sgt Poway high school
they're recognized everybody knows Poway
wrestling but the girls so there's
there's some areas in San Diego where
you have the the long-term plan where
you you know kids start wrestling really
young most when my daughter was
wrestling when she was like a junior and
senior in high school the other girls
that were really really good almost
every single one of them as I would talk
to him they almost all came from
jiu-jitsu Bay then they get to high
school and there's no Jiu Jitsu in high
school so they wrestle and then all of a
sudden they realize oh all this
grappling stuff that I've been doing for
the last six years you know it all kind
of applies and with boys it's the
opposite boys go from they go from
wrestling to jujitsu you know because
they get done with high school if they
don't go to college that what am I gonna
do now well you're gonna you're gonna
you know do Jiu Jitsu so um
good good Jiu Jitsu
summarized instructor okay here's how
you choke someone on the ground me but
how do I get them on the ground
wrestling summarized instructor okay
here's how to take someone down me okay
what do i do from there that's it's
pretty funny yeah I need it's it's it's
you know a little bit of a couple
comical yeah
what else wrestling all day wrestlers
are tough I have such a hard time with
wrestlers here's the check that's why
what you can give here's the other thing
you give your kids when you get them
into wrestling is your they're gonna get
competition yeah they're gonna get
competition and you're gonna compete
you're gonna go compete you know five
times on the weekends you're gonna do
five matches on the weekends and then
you're gonna wrestle at dual meet during
the week and you're gonna do that for
whatever three straight months and then
you're gonna go to regionals sectionals
and regionals and state like it's
there's a lot of competition and
everyone's good so that's good okay I
was a wrestler for six years and
reasonably good at the entire debate
between these two forms of the best
sport in the world seems pointless if
you achieve a certain amount of success
in either form of grappling you are one
of the most elite athletes in the world
you have a combination of strength speed
agility mental toughness that surpasses
the very top competitors and in other
sports oh this guy's is getting after it
you are the toughest of the tough the
baddest of the bad anybody willing to
step on the mat where you know with
complete certainty the other guy's gonna
try and rip you limb from limb and they
have trained hard for years just to come
whip your ass right here today
their only reason for even showing up is
to take you down and to stomp your dream
of reaching the top my friend
anybody who is willing to face that down
and fight back is a badass son of a gun
hats off to you regardless of what form
of grappling you choose it's 2:00 and it
could be argued that like wrestling is
harder is harder than jujitsu wear and
it's but it's harder in a certain well
it's gonna say because you can't
necessarily say that because you know
some people don't like striking like
even an MMA fighter an MMA fighter that
he does not look forward to sparring he
does not look forward to it at all it
doesn't look forward to getting hit
other people other MMA fighters they
love sparring they would rather spar
than do anything other MMA fighters the
last thing they want to do is that
grappling practice the shark tank
they don't want that at all so there's
some people that the grind of wrestling
would be easier than the grind of
jiu-jitsu there's some people vice-versa
however that being said if the broad
statement is wrestling is air quotes
harder I'm gonna have to say yes it's
hard work harder work harder grind yeah
yeah yeah there's no it seems like
harder because it's like this never
ending like chasm of like problems and
trying to solve them and once you solve
one it reveals two more it's like just
endless endless so that seems hard and
it seems like and again this is speaking
from someone with very limited wrestling
experience like actual wrestling
wrestling um it seems like and this is
remember vanilla gorilla Ryan yeah yeah
yes yes so he would always tell me these
these types of things where it's like no
you meet force with force in right you
know like it's simply the solution to
wrestling is go harder like a lot of the
time maybe sometimes some timing stuff
and stuff like that and this is what
he's telling me but it was like ya know
you meet force with force and that's
what you know that wrestling is kind of
thing like head to head boom boom just
did not like that so it'll it seems a
lot a lot more simple in that way
wrestling does but the work it takes
like you roll with a wrestler but get
ready to work if you want to fend him
off and then but then on top of that
even in jujitsu you can sort of figure
your way around the work you know if
you're if you're clever enough it's
possible it's the way it goes but I
think overall like you go to a wrestling
practice generally speaking like Jan or
the oh yeah and of course you go 200 a
vowel you know jump in his competition
Pat okay it's gonna be just as hard but
generally speaking you go to a typical
wrestling practice or a typical
jiu-jitsu practice it I I would guess
yes you're correct
you're correct yes you're correct that's
what that's what that's what that's why
wrestling is great to get your kids in
because they're gonna get that grind the
the people that yeah I did this big
experiment or not experiment research to
find out who makes it through SEAL
training the only two things that they
found that gave any sort of indication
was guys that wrestled and guys that are
from New England
seriously that's great you know and it
wasn't a huge it wasn't a huge deal you
know I whenever I go to a wrestling
tournament Marine Corps is always there
recruiting they know what's up yeah this
guy says where's my judo cos at not
getting much luck yeah we do does
awesome do does the Rudy Jiu Jitsu come
on man yeah and I and that's the reason
that I was like don't necessarily just
sit because wrestling let's face it like
you do have to have athletic ability
like the less athletic ability you have
the less successful kind of generally
speaking you'll the less success you'll
find in wrestling compared to jiu-jitsu
or even judo I had no competition judo
of course like any competition situation
yeah more I thought like you are the bet
the more success you're gonna find for
sure but as far as just doing it and
being successful like with the moves or
whatever it seems like and I've done
jutsu before where nothing much but I
have done it seems like if you know the
moves and the timing and the little you
know this it seems like the athletic raw
athletic part of it power strength speed
is less important not to say unimportant
but less important than when wrestling I
think wrestling has the highest level of
importance around athleticism
I think judo is number two and that's
not a very big margin in jiu-jitsu the
third yeah I guess I did wrestling in
high school I also had about five years
of Japanese karate and Aikido a couple
of times in my adult life where I was
forced to defend myself it was the rest
thing that saved me we didn't know about
jiu-jitsu back then the president I was
the president my University's MMA club
and I also formally wrestled in high
school it was so difficult teaching my
guys to wrestle they constantly
challenged the notion of fighting off
pins and fighting to defend to get
takedowns they failed the CBF the
efficacy of it and it was nearly
impossible to teach them because they
constantly wanted to pull guard or
easily went to their backs they really
fought for takedowns
it's extremely hard to teach someone who
has that jiu-jitsu background the
importance of simply wrestling the way
the only way I could was by smashing
them
yeah and forcing them to learn yeah
definitely the thing is jujitsu is so
much decided on the mat that to spend a
bunch of time and effort fighting for
the takedown as they say you could you
could do the pros and cons like you
could do a an analysis pros and cons to
see that whether it's worthwhile or not
to exert X amount of energy in the
takedown and you're probably gonna get
the fact that no it's not actually not
worth it yeah which is which is the sad
truth for jujitsu right
the sad truth for a street fight is if
you don't know how to defend a takedown
or you know how to put someone on the
ground if you need to that's a real
problem
so yeah Jiu Jitsu I hate to say this but
there's like a threat of laziness in it
right and actually this is when we read
the camp you know I was making fun of
myself saying like oh you know this is a
lazy way to do it so I liked it and
people would say no it's energy
conservation right its efficiency
there's so much efficiency in jiu-jitsu
that you can use it as a crutch to be
like cool I'm just gonna pull guard and
and it's all good I'll figure this out
once we're on the ground yeah yeah and
and when you think about it given a
certain philosophy that's a good thing
we're yeah do you know do we want to
expend all that energy for the sake of
winning a very specific fight right in a
fight by the way I end up on top and I'm
an added advantage but depending on the
guy on the bottom I may or may not be it
you know like it's it's an interesting
it's interesting calculus to figure out
that part of it yeah look we but here's
the deal ultimately we know to take down
and being on top is better that's just
the superior thing right we have that we
just know that is it better than each
individual specific scenario like if I'm
going against a wrestler how much time
it like a good wrestler how much time
I'm gonna waste trying to take him down
not very much because I'd rather get to
the mat where I can get busy now I'm
gonna make him work for it there's a
significant chance he's gonna pay a dear
price getting the takedown but for me to
think oh I'm gonna take him down no
yeah yeah you sort of just test the
waters and then then kind of go from
there
with the takedown situation yeah like
how you're saying like okay how much is
it worth it
right to fight for the takedown or do
you even defend the takedown some of the
time where you're gonna waste a bunch of
energy yeah and then okay is being on
the top worth more than being fresh
that's a good fresher debate you know
but if you know jiu-jitsu no it's not
worth it not at all right way rather be
fresh on the bottom being kind of tired
on top way rather yeah but if you only
know wrestling what's that what's the
answer
well I'd rate I'd rather be dead on top
then then hundred percent strength on
the bottom 100 percent typically that's
the case here's a good one I am
Australian played rugby my whole life I
picked up wrestling straight away it's
not difficult for me Jiu Jitsu on the
other hand I really struggle off my back
I'm okay on top controlling people but
put me on my back and I'm screwed I
usually just resort to scrambling and
wrestling to get to my feet especially
so there you have it some people that
have the genetic disposition to be to be
wrestlers it's hard for them to learn
jujitsu and there's people out of the
other way yeah kind of yeah it feels
like and obviously and this is the total
hypothesis if that but yeah it seems
like if you're an athletic person you
you know like when you first started you
Jitsu alright I mean I was like them a
lot of us are like this where if you
come if you come in with athletic
abilities like you kind of lean on those
athletic for sure especially at first so
yeah being on the bottom like you can be
the most athletic guy ever but really
all you know is just if to stand back up
yeah or to get back you know you don't
know the move you don't know sweeps you
don't know like that can or even
submissions a lot attempts and they're
not sharp for sure so yeah you just use
the athleticism and what effective
situation can you get out over into with
athleticism is just getting to you're
like hot like I was saying get your feet
or whatever yeah but you're when you're
on top you can hold the guy down with
all your strength and he can use some
technique if I mean unless it's super
sharp it's a little more intuitive to
hold someone down that is easier to
understand that than it is like how
you're gonna
maneuver your hips and feet to get
someone off you get to your to get back
up yeah here's a good one
devil's advocate here 9 times out of 10
seems a bit off if you're talking fine I
think I said like 9 times out of 10 the
jiu-jitsu guy would be like pure
jiu-jitsu versus pure wrestler I've done
both started and wrestling and I can
imagine and I can't imagine any pure
jiu-jitsu guy pulling guard and then
giving his head smashed on the concrete
he may not need subs when he's in an
actual fight if it's an actual fight
like you're arguing so this is a good
point this is one of the ones I was like
yeah you know when I when I was like
pure jiu-jitsu versus pure wrestling I
was like nine times out of ten the pure
jiu-jitsu guy's gonna win and that was
based off my experience we're on the
mats right cuz on the mats look hey
guarantee nine times out of ten the
wrestler gets the takedown he's getting
guillotine he's getting arm this is pure
wrestling or pure jiu-jitsu that's
what's gonna happen but now this guy
point taken legitimate point if it's a
fight that changes it quite a bit cuz
now when you hit the ground first of all
when the takedown happens you're getting
smashed onto the freakin concrete if
your uncle if you're on concrete so that
could be game over second of all once
you're down you're not just trying to
hold him your ground and pound you're
punching someone so that can change the
outcome so yes I agree with that one if
you're talking a real fight arrests that
are ver spear wrestler versus pure
jiu-jitsu wrestler has a better chance
in a real fight than he does in a
grappling match yeah why is that
I think circumstantial yeah like if you
go into specific scenarios or kind of
specific scenarios like well we're not
talking about we're talking broadly okay
so okay we'll start with a comment where
he was like heads smashed off the
concrete or a sec okay so that would
mean that the wrestler and who is
capable by the way he would have to do a
takedown or do something that would
actually smash a jiu-jitsu get hit on
the concrete and that's why I said if
you're even on concrete so okay you
choose a fight where you choose to fight
someone on the concrete okay and that
specific scenario on top of the fact
that he doesn't take down or a situation
like if a die straight up pulls gar
and then he does the slam to slam the
gate city on the concrete there is it's
possible yeah one thing one thing that's
interesting also that I just thought of
in jiu-jitsu in pure jiu-jitsu you
learned some wrestling yes in pure
wrestling
you don't learn jujitsu
they don't go hey by the way you might
get an arm lock here they don't go hey
this is a Kimura Yeah right
they don't say this is a guillotine this
is how you can choke someone in in
jiu-jitsu if you learn in pure Jiu Jitsu
you're getting taught a double leg
takedown this right you're getting
taught that you're getting taught a
single leg takedown you're getting
caught us taught a seatbelt there's all
kinds of things that you actually will
learn directly from wrestling yeah so if
you is that still considered pure right
is it pure Jiu Jitsu if you got taught
how to do a double leg takedown and how
to defend it you learned it injured you
never went to resting your life but you
still learned it you could go to
wrestling your whole life and never
learn an arm lock for sure okay for sure
you could go to wrestling your whole
life and you'd never learn the Chimaera
yeah for sure so that makes it a little
bit interesting too so well the reason I
was thinking that is because you said
well well you'd have to have a wrestler
that was capable of shooting a
good-enough double to get in deep and
then smash the guy on the ground right
on the concrete on the concrete and then
I thought well what's interesting about
that is anyone that's been training
jiu-jitsu for a little while
knows the double knows the counter and I
was gonna he's not gonna become her it
great but he's gonna at least know it
it's not like it's a blind blind
situation at the very least he's gonna
know how to not get his head smashed on
the concrete or the grass or the
wherever they're fighting at the very
least and and then that brings you to
the question like okay what do you mean
cured you Jitsu versus pure wrestling so
it's like are they on the same level so
let's say a level-10 wrestler versus the
level 10 jujitsu guy or let's say even
level 5 versus level 5 do just or you
know fine I'm just saying if they're
evenly matched yeah with their level I'm
starting to get frustrated with this
whole like this whole thing I think if
you narrow it down you can figure it out
is what I'm saying so a lot of these
comments and I dig it because I kind of
feel the same way where you when you
think
maybe your bias if you have one if you
think of your by so you think about a
top-level guy versus a run-of-the-mill
other guy yes but if you go you go nuts
- nuts no I don't think so I think the
judicious guys gonna win straight-up
like you get no now if you're like oh a
d1 college uh you have to you have to
you have to concede the fact that a
jujitsu guy let's say let's say on the
mat grappling match nine times out of
ten jiu-jitsu wins pure jiu-jitsu
against pure wrestling and the fact the
matter is that the wrestler doesn't
really know how to win so it's not
really even that fair he doesn't know
how to submit the person and that's how
the fight ends right so nine times out
of ten sure maybe the guy grabs his head
and can crank on it whatever would you
not concede to the fact that if you now
go straight a fight that the wrestler
has an advantage check it out because
let me say this to you now what's the
rest were gonna do he's trying to punch
this guy in the head he's not
necessarily trying to take him down now
if he's a really good wrestler in stings
are gonna be taking down so then again
that's why it gets frustrating because
we started just going into hypothetical
upon hypothetical upon hypothetical all
which leads to do wrestling and do
jiu-jitsu and combining and grapple and
train and strike and dumort I do
everything yeah agree boxing agree
because a good wrestler like a good
jiu-jitsu guy that has boxing right is
so much better off than a you could just
go down all these different paths the
paths all say train everything let's go
it's not what we're talking about in
this I don't know about you but in here
kids so it's up to Kenan Cornelius you
might know him sandy and he made a good
point with it where P liked it so that
people are so or we we all are actually
are so quick to be like yeah like
jiu-jitsu like like they're only gonna
be using like all their jujitsu moves
that they use in the tournament in a
street fight like no one's gonna like
try to try to jump a flying try always
make that clear yeah so like your
jujitsu becomes real basic in a street
fight real basic and it most of the time
I would
argue anyway no one's gonna do some move
that's gonna put them at risk of getting
their head slammed against Iran no one's
gonna do that
no one's gonna jump hard for sure you'll
never jump guard onto someone in a
street fight doesn't make sense I mean
put it this you have to be right yeah
just not knowing and it's just not
really you know so that and I think at
the end of the day when you really think
about it actually playing out I don't
think that generally speaking nine times
out of ten as it as it were I don't
think the jiu-jitsu guy would suffer all
these things that that people think you
would well you can't say that because
I'm saying he's gonna win nine times out
of ten okay here so what are you saying
it's ten out of ten and I'm saying not
all at nine times out of ten even in a
street fight if not ten even in a street
fight if they're evenly matched yes you
concede this the wrestler has a better
chance in a sraw Street fight than he
does on a grappling match yes okay I
would say that yes sir look anybody
that's sitting there going you know just
want to call BS on this whole thing
because you believe that Rhett look this
has already been proven like and look
wrestling with one month of jiu-jitsu is
a total GameChanger
it's all the game changer yes sir it's a
total game change it considered to in
the this is by no means proof but it's
it's an indicator it's evidence like you
okay USC for boys Gracie Dan Severn out
lead badass wrestler not a not a
beginner wrestler in fact you could even
argue that dancer sevens level wrestling
was higher than hoist Gracie's level of
jujitsu it could be argued yeah well
especially if you if you compare to
hoist to the level of jujitsu today
today it's the level you do today is
higher than the level of wrestling
jujitsu levels have gone up more than
wrestling levels have gone up in the
past whatever it's been 20 years yeah
and I would I don't doubt that either so
consider that fight oh it's crazy
hundred whatever 80 pounds however much
intense ever 24250 whatever he weighed
15-minute fight by the way so there's
some mental toughness in there and hoist
kc-1 submission so then the reason that
you say oh yeah wrestler would have a
better chance ministry fright then and
grappling match is because you can do
these things
are kind of intuitive like like punch
and elbow and do the things that you
don't need that you need some training
training does help for sure for sure but
if you're never trained in punching it
elbowing or whatever you can still
effectively punch in elbow somebody so
that's what kind of gives it more than
my effective yeah it makes more effect
cuz that's doing it yeah yeah yeah
so like a person that has never learned
how to throw a punch before or throw an
elbow is marginally effective compared
to somebody that actually leaves on the
box but we can I do agree the fact that
yes a person that's never trained out a
box before can throw a better punch then
someone that's never done jujitsu can do
an armlock yeah there's zero chance that
they're gonna get a knockout or get a
get an arm lock exactly so when you
throw that into the mix like okay
consider okay when I started you see my
first day of jujitsu I weighed 225
pounds I was into lifting and in that
kind stuff never was trained in boxing
or anything but I know or just don't
even take me take two you taking you
anyone who's like athletic and kind of
big put them mounted on somebody no
jujitsu training mounted on somebody
said beat him up punch him elbow him or
whatever no training in boxing or
elbowing beat him up all he'll beat you
up big-time
wait he's the guy on the bottom no
jujitsu no okay well yeah the fighter
what yeah it doesn't matter I'm just
saying like those elbows and punches are
gonna do a lot of damage now if you get
a guy know you did some experience put
them mounted and be like getting tap
this guy out oh yeah no jujitsu he
simply cannot do it the effectiveness is
literally zero zero so I'm just saying
you can throw inhave just rules alone
can make a person more effective so I'm
saying if you if you're going you know
in a real fight but what's the example
of that gen Severn Heights Gracie
boom they can do whatever they want you
know no rule situation they're grappling
that one and it was smaller and are if
you're less noise no never check he's
good juju - yeah
supercool let's see someone's a couple
people bring up catch wrestling which is
is awesome catch wrestling and we talked
about it on the video as well the guy
says uh that guy says what about
submission catch wrestling to take the
strengths of wrestling like takedown
skills and had the submissions be able
to finish and then he says at 7.50 six
he goes into catch wrestling a little
bit so yeah
definitely catch wrestling is awesome
and you got some catch wrestling
practitioners current and current day
Josh Barnett black belt in jujitsu by
the way ya can't maybe third degree yeah
yeah but his base is catch wrestling
he's a beast um let's see
Sakuraba as well but again like this is
like you know how they used to say
remember when mashita lyoto machida was
champ they were like oh see you karate
is better than jiu-jitsu well by the way
you know so it's kind of yeah you know
just like Josh Barnett and I'm not and
here's the thing I think catch wrestling
you get a badass catcher he can beat you
guys fresher cuz he has some missions he
has like the wrestling like yeah it's
poly I look at catch wrestling is
jiu-jitsu and wrestling combined that
matters yeah that's not even you know is
like this massive overlap it seems like
yeah but yes but Josh Barnett is argue
it could be said that Josh Burnett maybe
isn't the best example of how effective
catch wrestling is in and of itself
because he has black belt in jujitsu
this straight up so you know it's a I
have it's personality-driven
to like my my daughter who wrestled
ended jiu-jitsu which I'll they all do
but well one day all the digits you but
one of them wrestled too extensively but
she almost immediately when she started
wrestling I was like I like wrestling
better and I said well hi like well I
didn't say like that I said oh why do
you like dressing better she says it's
so simple like what I have to do is take
down the person and pin them yeah
there's not heel hooks and chokes and
arm and all these other things like no
I'm gonna get you on your back that's
what I'm gonna do so she liked that
simple
I would say my son on the other hand who
also does jiu-jitsu and wrestling I
would say even though during wrestling
season it's all wrestling given the
opportunity he man he likes to roll bad
juju ah
he's got that personality you know he
likes that he likes that the dang goggle
crotch yeah I think your daughter had it
has it correct in that way because in
wrestling it seemed like and again I
don't know you
your daughter has wrestling experience I
certainly don't so but it seems like it
yeah yeah well and the bottom line is
there's so much technique in wrestling
as well yeah crazy rich there's insane
there's an insane amount of technique in
wrestling for sure yeah no but hurt her
opinion on the simplicity of it it does
seem to be true it seem like if you're
on top interesting you know it's pretty
simple to know if you're winning or not
in jujitsu there's a big part of your
jujitsu kind of journey where you can
literally think you're winning but
you're losing or you can think oh yeah I
got him here but he kind of got you you
know there's a lot of that going on and
introduced to it seems like in wrestling
there's of course there is some of that
but there's like less of that it's like
more straightforward this is what it
seems like anyway check I can't wait
till you guys get to the point where the
listeners can call in and talk about the
things you say oh that's not even have
to do with this this subject I'd like to
hear Jocko has to say in regards to the
differences between jujitsu applied to
self-defense forces sport jujitsu how it
changes in regards to weapons multiple
attackers this is just like I can't I
can't do it I've answered it a thousand
times
um you know let's just move on with the
you know just Sakuraba checking it yeah
you already brought up a Sakuraba mm-hmm
somebody said one word khabib right dude
is an animal when it comes to take down
but khabib is a Sambo guy he's a
wrestler but he's a Samba guy which
again Sambo is really close to a mixture
of really
resting in jiu-jitsu you know mr. Samba
that too by the way yeah Dean Lister
two-time national champion champion
Samba guy by the way what else did you
think sport versus fighting or Street
Street self-defense whatever was put
simply before what in which I thought
was was more or less accurate worse I
think it was like John Jacques Machado
mighta said it I'm not sure what did you
say
he said that Street our sport jiu-jitsu
is doing jiu-jitsu against another guy
doing jiu-jitsu against you the street
fighting or self-defense is doing
jiu-jitsu against a guy not using
jiu-jitsu yeah that's and what you have
to translate that one step further which
is doing jiu-jitsu against someone that
doesn't know what they're doing and you
don't really saying yeah yeah I mean of
course you could go down the rabbit hole
where it's like even if you fight on the
street self-defense with a guy who also
knows jujitsu you're not gonna go gee
it's not gonna be like a jujitsu match
is I'm saying no but if it's like okay
this guy's gonna bring as much jujitsu
as possible in a sports situation you're
gonna bring all your jiu-jitsu soon
saying so it's like juicy against you
too kind of thing I think that's sort of
what he meant
sure but of course there's a lot more
details to it but simply speaking I
liked it a here's I gotta roll into this
one the issue I have with these
comparisons is that they always default
to jiu-jitsu rules I'm not a disciple of
either but wrestling guy pins a jujitsu
guy much faster than a jujitsu guys
submits a wrestler equal level of
training ability that's fine but the
whole point of this is that is that
panic getting pinned doesn't mean you
lose a real fight at all that's what
that's what this is it doesn't mean so
yeah it defaults to its rules because
jiu-jitsu has a finite ending you tap
out that's the end of the match
wrestling is you hold someone down which
isn't the fight is not over
yeah can you and obviously I don't know
all the pins in wrestling but is there a
pin in wrestling that's really easy to
hold someone that you could hold them
there for 30 minutes yeah yeah just like
a side control right that's a pin in
wrestling
just being inside control you're
painting the person you can hold someone
there for half an hour if you wanted to
yeah but we are using in the rules no no
no no yeah I mean what you think I mean
like they're a one that exists cuz like
side control okay
I mean to piano guy where he can't move
inside control takes like you can't do
that for 30 minutes like you can lay on
them for 30 minutes and he'll have
opportunities to escape within 30
minutes since uh I think that I could
hold many people inside control on their
back pin for 30 minutes if that was the
test yeah you could because your side
control is like good but you wouldn't be
like holding their head as hard as you
possibly you know how someone has a
tight cut side control like um like the
the moment where someone's trying to get
their points for that first three
seconds okay that that's like that seems
like anyway an example of like an actual
pin that seems like you're actually
painting the gun you are pinning the guy
right so but once you sort of let go of
that that the tension so to speak that's
where this guy can create opportunities
to escape will say right okay so in
wrestling it's in that this is a
question I have like it wrestling it
seems like anytime a guy who has pinned
me for like Greg or someone would show
me an example of a pin I feel like it's
kind of that first three seconds of side
control where I can't escape even if I
go hard right now I can't escape this
pain for sure for sure but is there a
pin where it's so dominant that the guy
doesn't have to use like you know energy
up you know there's a ton of them
including just side control right like
when I get psyched or which which in
wrestling you can get people that you're
looking to that's literally what you're
trying to do is get control of them most
a lot of the pins come from a site
control looking position yeah so yeah
there's wrestlers that could pin you
have you ever been put inside controlled
by a really good wrestler yeah they're
painting you and you can't get out yeah
but if you give me 30 minutes I can
possibly yes but even okay so let me
explain it better I guess okay so even
you put me inside control huh right you
put me inside control I could like spat
I'm not saying when you have me in the
tension shoulder in the new jaw you know
that first three seconds it's like
control
the regular site control you're trying
to hold me there for 30 minutes
absolutely I could like if I'm strong
enough and have enough energy I can like
spaz and get to my knees I'll get your
hundred percent yes but I could get out
of sight good yeah I don't another
condition I don't agree with that I
think if we can if the goal for me was
just to hold you inside control yeah I
you know yeah you could get out but
there's at least a 75% chance that half
an hour goes by and you're just down
there in side control exhausted yeah so
do you think even if that were true
which I'm not gonna say it's not true
Ness there's been remember when you were
claustrophobic for a while yeah okay so
yeah there were times where my I would
just hold you inside control just to
make you suffering and trying to help
you overcome that that issue right thank
you for keeping that by the way but
nonetheless and I believe me it would
you know what maybe maybe thirty minutes
didn't go by but like eight would go by
and and it wasn't like your chances of
escaping were increasing as time went on
because I wasn't getting tired and in
this idea that I was up there gorilla
gripping no it's like it's my wing and
gravity but it's not just your weight
it's like you're adjusting your way
you're shifting everything when I
reverse this you can if you get if you
got a good side control me and then you
were like okay my goal is just to hold
you you could hold me there for a long
time in fact most of the time when I
escape from someone it's because they
you gotta bait them with something else
right if you're like hey I'm not gonna
go for any of these little armed
exposures that jockle gives me all these
neck exposures I'm not gonna take them
I'm just gonna hold him here it would be
really hard for me to get out yeah
really hard okay I would have to
psychologically torment you to where you
go for something and then I get out or
even like I'm over had a judo guy get
like the scarf upon you yes sir you're
not getting you have to let them except
you have to give them something that
they think they can take to get them to
maneuver so there's a whole that
hopefully opens up and if they say no
I'm not taking the bait you're just
gonna sit there longer yeah just wait
longer yeah that's true I felt the
classic like when you said a good judo
guys scarf scarf old with Iggy that's
rough yeah so yeah so in jujitsu zone
okay moving one step kind of further
then so in jujitsu like
if you get a guy a back mount body lock
on Oh mm-hmm one over water lock but
luck meaning we have body body triangle
yes you know one over one under as far
as arm position on your back you could
stay there for a long time straight up
and the guy would have no recourse he
couldn't move around maybe for sure more
but you know there's there's a lot of
those weird like they're not necessarily
pins like pin the guy on his back but
you give it to these positions that the
guy simply can't get out of check
this guy says so I want to become a
carpenter but I can't decide if I should
buy a hammer or a tape measure which is
more important like if I had to choose
one and he says this is nonsense and
it's ride me bananas one isn't better
than the other love wrestling love
jiu-jitsu love judo it's all grappling
yeah props yeah is this person said is
it really so difficult to answer the
question he actually asked oh my god
wasted six minutes sorry bro you're on
YouTube that you know one o'clock in the
morning you know if we're worried about
these six minutes that you're wasting
there's a lot of other things you're
wasting so let's not let's not head down
that road it's just gonna gonna bum you
out
mm-hmm the toolbox thing kind of
reinforces what you're saying learn
everything right so it's like you know
ya die with the hammer is better off
than the guy with nothing guy with the
what is it tape measure eight measures
better I'll forget nothing
the guy with the hammer versus the guy
with the tape measure you know it
depends on what they're doing obviously
but the guy with both oh that guy can
get some fun stuff right there yeah
imagine you throw a saw in there now he
can do anything this guy says it also
depends on the form of jujitsu you are
comparing cop tomato jujitsu is more of
a standing form compared to Brazilian
when I talk about jujitsu I'm only
talking about one kind of jujitsu and
that's Brazilian jiu-jitsu well I I need
to make that clear more often
what else this guy just said beautiful
answer and discussion prompts while we
give you a little bit more here a little
another little taste on that grounded
podcast what else I'll read one more of
these things before we just completely
beat this dead horse oh yeah there you
go to answer the question in real-world
practice Ben Askren versus Demian Maia
Ben Askren is a God Tyr Olympic wrestler
he was put to sleep by a god tier BJJ
practitioner whatever the that's that
sort of proves the point in a way but
then you could go out in sight a million
examples of wrestlers that beat the hell
out of jujitsu guys God Tyr though I'm
not saying it's not true I'm saying that
that's a to me that when they use
examples of this person versus this
person or whatever there's look there
seems to be more to it than that because
Damon guy has good wrestling as well
maybe not like it the same level as
Damon Maya but it's kind of like the
Josh Barnett situation where it's like
yeah I catch wrestling these questions
so it's so good that he just beats and
taps out Dean but I mean well yes he has
good catch wrestling but he has black
belt level Jiu Jitsu as well so you know
Demian Maia you know even though he did
yes he did tell him up but he does have
wrestling soon saying so it's like it's
not uh what do you call like a clean
it's not fair it's not pure
it's not pure one of the other I take a
wrestler over Jiu Jitsu in the street
fight personally you don't really need
to choke someone out after you suplex
them on concrete bigness some replies to
that I agree that BJJ guy could win
against the wrestler on a BJJ
competition but in an MMA match where a
ground pounders Allah
alright well anyways all we probably did
is create more comments on this but
interesting discussion I think overall
what we're saying is what I'm saying is
train grappling of course train striking
- but train train that's what you needed
you train wrestling train jujitsu train
judo train it all
trained boxing trained muy Thai trained
everything that's my conclusion okay for
now current that's your current and
sorry it's been a while since we did a
grounded podcast but we will try and do
them a little more often if you want to
train any of these grappling arts we can
help you mm-hmm by getting you the gear
you need Vikki the rash guard go to
origin mein kampf or made in America
from from the dirt to the shirt porridge
in mein dot-com if you want to support
the podcast a little bit you can check
out Jocko store.com
we got shirts and rash guards and other
assorted
things stuff that all helps support this
appreciate it and until next time stay
grounded